Welcome to toxic Kirkland's.
Uh,
I'd like to welcome Brian deer.
He's the author of the book,
the friendly Orange Glow.
And the book was the first.
It is the first to tell the story of the Pluto system and its relation to the
dawn of cyber culture,
uh,
before becoming an author.
Uh,
Mr deer was the founder and the chairman of eventful incorporated.
The makers of had been full.com the world's largest event search engine.
He was also the founding director of Ebay design labs at Ebay.
And he's also been in,
been in management at Easel,
mp3.com flat works,
real networks and coconut computing.
And he actually owns the domain coconut.com I found out.
So let's welcome Mr Brian deer.
So thanks for coming.
So,
if this is the first historical work,
uh,
I'm assuming that a lot of people don't even know what Plato is.
So do you mind giving us a overview?
Sure,
yeah.
I mean,
it,
it is remarkable that it is so largely unknown.
I mean,
it was a pretty major government project that was funded by the same agencies
that funded Arpanet.
Anything,
any takers,
Arpanet,
um,
uh,
Arpa and NSF or the major backers of Plato.
Um,
the p l a t o stands for programmed logic for automatic teaching operations,
a real tongue twister.
Um,
uh,
the project started in 1960 and at the University of Illinois at Urbana
Champagne.
And the idea was to,
um,
you have to understand that this,
this was right after,
uh,
let's see,
it would've been three years,
basically two and a half years after Sputnik got launched by the Soviet Union.
And that kind of freaked out the u s government and it freaked out the media and
it freaked out a lot of politicians,
um,
that the u s was weak in science and math and engineering education because
clearly the Soviets beat us to launch a rocket into space.
And so what were we going to do about this?
And suddenly there was this massive flow of funding out of the congress starting
at 1958 at the same time NASA was started and Arpa was started.
And tons of fun funding started flowing into universities and companies to do
something about improving what we would call stem education today.
Um,
and the University of Illinois had a lab that had been set up during the Korean
War called the coordinated science lab.
Actually at the time it was called the control systems lab.
They renamed it coordinated science lab keeping the CSL so the US government
would have no trouble continuing to write checks,
you know,
um,
but,
uh,
they were trying to move away from being a military classified lab doing mainly
research on our radar systems and air traffic control.
Very similar to the,
uh,
radiation lab at Mit that some of you may have heard of from World War II.
Um,
there's lots of books on the history of that.
So anyway,
Plato emerged with the idea,
like,
could we do a civilian project,
uh,
to apply a computer to be a teacher and instruct students who sit down in front
of it on any academic subject.
And it's pretty remarkable that they were doing this in 1960 only a few years
after a psychologist,
BF Skinner at Harvard was kicking around ideas with teaching machines.
And the first chapter of my book is all about what he was up to and how his
timing was really good because when Sputnik arrived,
suddenly everyone looked at teaching machines and what was called programmed
instruction as maybe a new way to really help,
uh,
educate a lot more people because there weren't enough teachers and that kind of
thing.
So Plato started as a pure educational project to turn a computer,
which at the time was the Iliac,
which is one of the big old vacuum tube,
you know,
uh,
monoliths from,
from the fifties when they were only a handful of computers in the world.
And,
you know,
it would,
it would fit in this room,
but you know,
uh,
it,
it was all vacuum,
thousands of vacuum tubes that failed,
you know,
in a week or something like that each.
Um,
so we were constantly replacing it.
But yeah,
so that's what Plato originally was.
What makes the story interesting?
Is that what it became later.
Um,
and I argue it kind of became a precursor to much of what we take for granted
today on the net a lot before people realize was possible.
Right.
Yeah.
So my next question was about the first that Plato wrote about,
uh,
reading through the first part of your book.
You talk about a lot of technological Ferris with the touch screens in the
plasma displays and such,
and then you move into a social and human interaction changes in the first where
you get into the cyber culture and the social networks and things that evolved.
Uh,
maybe we'll start at the beginning with the technological changes and just what
was the things that Plato with on the cutting edge and then defining adjuncts?
Well,
it was way beyond before cutting edge.
It was like bleeding edge,
you know,
rough,
blunt edge.
It was,
um,
I mean they had to basically build and construct everything from scratch,
both software and hardware.
They had an Iliac box the size of this room.
Um,
they didn't have any terminals.
They didn't have any graphics that they,
they didn't have any memory.
They had no telecom capability,
noon,
no networking,
uh,
they had no software.
Everything was machine code,
really,
really primitive.
Just maybe one notch up from Zeros and ones,
but it wasn't even assembly language.
And,
um,
that's what you programmed the ILIAC can.
And so that was where they started.
And one of the things they realized right away was,
you know,
if you're going to teach students,
you need to have a graphical display.
They understood that they had been exposed to projects like sage,
which was a gigantic military,
uh,
that,
that involved real graphical displays and had been built for billions of
dollars.
Um,
so the technology was known.
It was just insanely expensive and not practical.
And just to give you guys an idea of,
of the cost compared to,
you know,
we now have even one person holding a smartphone in this room has more memory
than all computers combined in the world,
probably until the 70s,
I'm guessing.
Um,
you know,
with a few gay 16 Gig,
right?
Um,
in the Plato,
when Plato started,
uh,
one idea was for d the display,
they would use video ram and a CRT.
And so they went off and bought a,
uh,
they found a used $10 television set that the tuner was broken,
but hey,
it had,
it was a CRT and it works.
So that's all they needed.
They didn't need the tuner.
Um,
and,
uh,
then they were,
we're trying to figure out how to do memory and ram in 1960,
61 62 was $2 per bit.
So do the math on your 16 gig phone,
right?
Or 64,
one 28 gig phone.
Um,
we're talking a couple hundred million dollars.
so even then to have a five,
12 by five,
12 pixel display,
which is what the idea was,
it was going to cost hundreds and hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And just,
you know,
for students in schools that,
when teachers can't even afford chalk to put on the blackboard,
it just was not going to be economics weren't there.
So they had to come up with something else.
And what they came up with was an idea that actually had been kicked around for
quite a while.
It turned out of using,
uh,
gaseous discharge,
um,
uh,
gas plasma discharge in an,
if you built an array of conductors,
one going vertically when going horizontally and you,
uh,
ran electricity through any intersection of it,
of the,
the conductors in theory,
you could basically light up one little cell that had neon gas or some other
kind of gas in it.
And the,
the holy grail was can you make that a gaseous cell,
have memory and have essentially you could send a,
set it in such a state that it would stay lit.
And if you could do that,
then you basically have a memory cell and,
and,
and it would be a lot cheaper than ram and stuff like that.
So they worked on that for years and they tried everything they could do.
They,
they,
uh,
they wound up,
um,
uh,
with a breakthrough in 1964.
And I talk about that in the book where they,
they finally,
uh,
build a single pixel,
a display.
That's all they had.
They were using.
If,
if,
as a kid,
you remember if you ever played with a microscope and you know the little square
pieces of glass that you put on top of a slide and a microscope.
And then you look at some parameciums or something,
those little tiny thin wafer wafers of glass,
they create a sandwich of them.
And the one,
so there were three sheets of glass.
The one inside had a little dot drilled through it.
And that was the pixel.
And they,
and they managed to get neon gas into it.
And,
uh,
normally neon gas glows orange a just click a campfire,
but some nitrogen from just normal air had leaked into the tube and it glowed
blue.
But that was their breakthrough.
And it actually,
if you send a certain amount of electricity through a spike and the signal and
then you send a smaller sustaining voltage through the pixel stay lit and that
is literally a one and you can send an then a drop in the voltage and the pixel
go off and that's zero.
And um,
but they had achieved memory and a display.
So,
you know,
by 1972,
they had five,
12 by five,
12 versions of these with orange pixels.
And literally when you're sitting down at,
at one of these screens,
you are viewing the memory.
There is no ram that it's,
you know,
refreshing constantly like 60 hertz or something.
It's,
you're looking at the memory.
So it was a pretty ingenious invention.
And they also realized,
you know,
if we had three pixels per pixel and we use different color phosphorous,
we could have RGB and we could have color,
you know,
and so they actually put that in the patent.
Um,
so they invented plasma televisions and this and,
and it turned out to be a really lucrative patent that,
uh,
poured millions of dollars into University of Illinois and help fund Plato for
many,
many years.
Uh,
lots of companies,
Fujitsu,
IBM,
NCR,
all kinds of companies would license that patent.
Um,
and you know,
plasma displays wound up in everything from a checkout counters at the grocery
store to,
uh,
you know,
airline ticket counters and banks and nuclear submarines wanted flat panel
displays cause the CRTs took up too much room.
So it wound up everywhere.
So awesome.
And so the books differently,
orange glow did the,
when did Plato switchover to the RGV display and never know because it was just
too expensive.
And in fact,
I mean there were prototypes.
They had colored,
uh,
displays in the lab.
I remember seeing one in the 80s.
Um,
IBM built one,
they built like a 10,
24 by 10,
24,
I think it was plasma color display,
but you know what,
it would've cost $100,000 or something.
So it wasn't practical.
Um,
it was only one Fujitsu came out with the 42 inch plasma vision,
like in the mid nineties or something.
That was the first plasma television that you could buy and hang on the wall.
It would only set you back about 15 grand,
you know?
Um,
so they,
they became dirt cheap over time,
but um,
you know,
amazing.
So technologically it's like you said,
bleeding edge,
but then,
uh,
it started as a teaching system and then you stayed at evolve to something else.
It's more of a network system.
So let's talk a little bit,
I mean,
they always had this dream of scaling the system up.
it's kind of funny when you look back at project,
I mean,
you hear about scale in any startup today,
right?
I mean,
the whole dream is you build a product,
we build a service and you got to scale it up and you're,
you're,
you know,
you,
you throw it into the cloud,
some cloud service,
and you have virtual servers and it's all,
you know,
um,
people nowadays don't realize how good they have it compared to what they were
dealing with.
And Plato,
I mean,
one of the jokes in the Plato era,
I heard this from people all the time when I interviewed them was,
you know,
every bit is sacred.
And you know,
when you were coding,
um,
you know,
a,
a program on a Plato,
you might get,
you know,
about a thousand words of memory.
And so you literally had to worry about allocating in,
assigning real meaning to a single bit rather than,
you know,
oh,
we'll just to a long two to a binary value or something.
You know,
you just,
you did not have that luxury.
Um,
it's kind of funny.
I think Microsoft word probably exceeded the entire cyber,
uh,
s all of Plato,
all of its programs,
all of its data and everything in,
in,
you know,
in footprint,
in terms of data.
Uh,
probably years ago,
you know,
any big APP nowadays is kind of bloated compared to what the Plato people were
facing.
Everything was scarce and every single aspect of the system,
uh,
you,
you really had to think carefully because it just wasn't,
there wasn't the luxury of like,
of resources we have now.
And he said cyber,
cyber is the operating system that ran under,
well,
yeah,
no,
what happened was,
um,
in,
uh,
so played off,
started with the ILIAC computer,
which was completely inadequate and all the other professors and researchers on
campus,
we're also using that thing,
which means you had to sign up for time.
It wasn't a timesharing system.
Um,
so you know,
you basically,
you might get 2:00 AM or something like that.
And the way you programmed the Iliac is that you worked on paper for days or
maybe even weeks beforehand,
and your time on the Iliac was actually trying to compile that program and it
better work because if it didn't you,
you,
you would probably blown the hour that you had.
And so you'd have to go back through,
you know,
the equivalent of core dumps,
I guess,
and try to figure out how to,
you know,
uh,
where there was a bug and then the next time,
maybe a week later or something like that,
you might get another 2:00 AM session to run it again.
So it was insanely,
and I add an inadequate as a development environment.
So,
uh,
the CSL,
put out bids for a better computer and IBM and control data both came in with
offer,
you know,
with RFPs or whatever.
Uh,
control data came in with a $995,000,
a CDC 1604,
which at the time was like a pretty fast machine.
Uh,
IBM came in with big iron machines,
uh,
for about a million dollars.
When they saw that CDC was like five bucks less.
They said,
oh,
well,
okay,
we'll sell it to you for $500,000 a control data came back and told the
university,
ours is nine 95 from a so IBM came back and said,
we'll sell it to you for $250,000 and control database came back and said,
no,
ours is still $995,000.
Uh,
long story short,
the University of Illinois,
I bought the control data machine for $995,000.
Ibm was furious,
sued and did all the typical stuff that companies do.
Wound up in a huge battle in the state legislature.
Um,
you know,
when all the dust settled,
IBM was,
it went off very upset and control data got the deal and that kind of changed
the whole history of Plato from then on because,
um,
the first thing they did was build an Iliac emulator in the 1604.
So there were back to running iliac again,
but it was all emulate it and it was much faster and they had time and then they
started knowing all the professors around campus yet again because Plato was
starting to consume way too much of its time.
And uh,
so,
uh,
in a couple of years they got a,
a second 1604 for a dollar.
And that really sealed the fate of Plato because from then on they basically had
a relationship with control data that was the architecture for the rest of time.
And by the early seventies,
they were,
they had always had this dream of scale to get up to thousands of simultaneous
users.
Um,
by then,
CDC had a real supercomputer,
um,
the,
the cyber,
uh,
6,400 6,600 series,
massive mainframes,
very multimillion dollar machines.
And they bought one for Plato.
And that's what,
uh,
Plato started running on around 71 72.
And that's when things got weird because,
um,
by then the,
uh,
the lab,
it got much bigger.
Um,
there was a huge influx of people and this,
this lab was very unusual and I don't think they were,
I'm not aware of another lab in the 70s,
a computer lab on a university campus in the United States that would have been
similar to this.
Um,
every other one I've heard of,
MIT,
Stanford,
whatever,
they were pretty locked down places and you'd have,
you had to have access to get in.
And so they were limited and you didn't have a bunch of kids come ring the local
high schools wandering into the building.
Um,
if you tried to do that,
you'd probably get kicked out and your parents would probably get called,
you know,
that kind of thing.
But at the University of Illinois,
at the Plato Lab,
um,
they encourage people to wander in and there just happened to be a high school
across the street.
And sure enough,
all the geeks from that school just wandered into Plato saw these incredibly
amazing,
you know,
five,
12 by five,
12 graphics displays had built in touch screens on them and people were doing
amazing things with graphics.
You know,
in 72 and 73 and they were not getting kicked out.
In fact,
they were encouraged to sit down and start programming.
So a lot of them learn how to code.
And uh,
starting around 1973,
there was this amazing 12 month period where the whole Plato system really
completely changed in nature.
It had been all about education.
The kids,
ironically,
the recipients of the education that they were supposed to get out of playdough
took one look at it and saw that the development environment and realize,
you know,
we could do other kinds of things with this,
including,
you know,
inter-terminal kinds of things,
including interpersonal kinds of things.
So chat rooms started up,
um,
there was an app called Talkomatic,
instant messaging,
uh,
fired up in,
in December of [inaudible] 73,
um,
email and,
uh,
what were called notes files,
which are the equivalent of message board or it's a message forums,
use net and that kind of thing.
All those things started.
Uh,
there was an online newspaper and then there was a whole raft of a nonstop games
being built.
And these were all multiplayer multiuser games,
muds and Dungeon Games.
They were all graphical.
Um,
and all this started by the teenagers from the high schools and an undergrads.
It was never part of the National Science Foundation Mission to,
you know,
build off this recreational social stuff.
But you know,
what struck me,
and it only struck me after I finished writing the book was that,
you know,
if you look at this history that's laid out of this project and you see what
they built so early,
um,
you realize that the,
you know,
I,
I kind of describe it as,
um,
the interpersonal computer revolution.
Um,
uh,
started before the personal computer revolution ever started.
You know,
before apple was incorporated before,
uh,
the Altair was out,
I think certainly before Microsoft was incorporated.
Um,
I'll put it another way.
While Larry and Sergey were still in diapers,
um,
uh,
Plato was booming with this online culture,
um,
that had all the kind of apps that got people addicted.
And they were,
you know,
they're,
they,
they were having the rush in 1973 that we hear talked about today with social
networks.
And Twitter and Facebook and a Google plus,
you know,
um,
uh,
but,
yeah,
it,
it's just a remarkable because there's no computer history book.
There's no museum that has a timeline that shows that,
you know,
all this advanced stuff was going on really early then it kind of,
and it didn't really even die off.
It just was a parallel universe almost.
That very strangely got ignored.
And,
um,
you know,
uh,
how many of you show of hands have ever heard of the book hackers heroes of the
computer revolution by Steve Leavey?
Good.
Well,
the,
those who haven't get it,
it's worth it.
It's a,
it's a great book.
It's a great story.
Came out in 1984.
It's still in print.
Um,
I think Riley has a printout now.
It's what inspired me to do this book cause I always felt,
you know,
the first thing I did when I bought that was I rushed to open the index and look
under p for Plato,
Nada.
And there has,
and that's the way it's been ever since.
Um,
even Walter Isaacson's recent book,
the innovators doesn't have a single mention of Plato in it,
which is absolutely remarkable.
Um,
but then at the sea,
so on the one hand I'm kind of frustrated and I want to like,
you know,
rant at them for like,
why didn't you,
you know,
blah,
blah.
But on the other hand,
what we're,
what resources did they have to even know about Plato?
If you,
if you didn't know someone or if you didn't use it yourself,
it really was a,
you had to be there kind of thing,
which is really unfortunate.
I mean,
you know,
uh,
probably me,
I'm assuming none of us here were at Xerox Park,
but we probably mostly know about that history.
It's been well documented.
It's been great books about it,
and it,
you know,
it profoundly influenced the industry.
You know,
the,
the Lisa and the Macintosh and windows and all that stuff.
Um,
and they're,
you know,
there's been great books about that,
but there's never been a book about Plato.
So I always felt that it was desperately needed so that we can get Plato into
the conversation.
And,
uh,
no longer live in a world that's kind of ignorant of it because it's pretty
remarkable.
So you have a passion for it and an interest in it,
and there's no books about it.
So you had to discover it somewhere.
So what,
what,
how did you meet Plato,
I guess?
Um,
well,
I,
I come from five generations of newspaper publishers and editors.
Um,
uh,
my father's father,
his father's father,
his father's felt going back to like 1850.
They owned The Jersey City Journal,
which was the second largest paper in the New York Metro area.
You know,
um,
I think it's still around,
but anyway,
um,
so I grew up in a household of like 10 daily newspapers.
My hands were always black from the ink.
You know,
I loved reading newspapers.
I was a Watergate junkie as a kid.
Um,
and,
uh,
so I entered the University of Delaware as a freshman in 1979 with the idea,
I guess I'll be English slash journalism and maybe,
you know,
go work in a newspaper,
that was the family business.
And,
um,
I was wandering around campus literally the first week I was there of walking
through the music building.
And there was a room that I just,
you know how in a lot of university,
uh,
classrooms,
there'll be a door to the classroom entrance,
but then there's like a glass window,
Florida ceiling and you can kind of look in,
right?
Well the lights were off in this room,
but I saw that the,
all these faces were in there sitting down and terminals with their headphones
on and they were all like reaching out and touching the screen like that.
And I'm looking at it and there's very crisp high resolution graphics depiction
of musical notation.
And then there's a keyboard,
like a piano keyboard at the bottom of the screen and they're all like
interacting.
They're clearly listening to the music they're playing.
And I was pretty impressed cause I mean,
I thought,
you know,
seventies computing was like scrolling Ascii or VT 100 if you're lucky,
you know.
Um,
so I went in and they didn't kick me out.
I checked it out.
There was a big poster on the wall saying,
welcome to Plato.
I had no idea what it was.
And um,
I found out real fast.
I mean I felt,
you know,
I sat down and within a few minutes I hear there's,
someone's cracking up laughing at another terminal and you know,
I wasn't used to the idea that people would laugh at something on a computer and
they were chatting with somebody and then someone that was someone else was
reading a hilarious message that someone had posted and one of the notes files.
And there were,
and,
and then I,
it dawned on me that they weren't all their learning.
They were a lot of more interacting with people on the other side of the screen
somewhere else on the campus.
Or I didn't,
I didn't know how far this extended,
you know,
they,
there were other people out there using terminals two and then it dawned on me
that University of Delaware was kind of like this remote island.
It wasn't the cool place that,
you know,
the cool place was the University of Illinois,
which was where Plato had started.
And then I discovered that the Delaware Plato system was connected kind of like
an a poor man's internet.
It had a dedicated link to a control data Plato system in Minneapolis,
which connected to Illinois.
And then there were other systems around the world and Canada and Europe,
uh,
all the way down in South Africa.
And most of them were interconnected and you could send email to anybody and,
and that just kind of blew me away.
Um,
so yeah,
the,
the degree in English slash journalism lasted about a week and then it was
pretty much a degree in,
played out since then,
so.
Awesome.
And so at the,
at the time when you met Plato were first started using player then it was
already a worldwide network.
Oh,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I had nothing to do with building the system or anything.
I was just a user and,
um,
I just couldn't believe that this thing was so cool and,
you know,
uh,
and it would,
it also did was completely spoil me from the microcomputer revolution,
which was raging at the time that I,
apple two was out of the Commodore Peck.
Pat had come out,
um,
I guess the TRS 80 or whatever was called from radio shack.
And then the IBM PC came out in 81,
you know,
the Lisa came out,
um,
and a few years later,
and then the Mac and,
you know,
I looked at all this stuff and it's like,
why would anyone want to sit down at a lonely,
disconnected,
you know,
kind of toy computer.
There's no people in that box.
There's no way to chat and interconnect with them.
The,
you know,
there's,
there's nothing,
there's nothing addictive about it.
And yet they were all addicted to pcs.
And I'm like,
but look at this.
This is,
Plato is much more interesting.
This is the future that's like,
Eh,
you know,
future people.
The people is the killer APP.
You know,
I think Plato,
people understood that from day one.
Um,
and,
uh,
I arrived late on the scene,
but,
you know,
I immediately picked up on it and I saw it.
This,
this was clearly going to be the future or our doom or both.
You know,
and I,
I think we're,
I think we can agree.
It's both.
You know,
so,
oops,
oops.
Now I just,
uh,
but,
so,
yeah,
no problem.
So,
uh,
whereas Plato now,
like is it still operable?
Uh,
well,
you know,
it's,
it's like any of these vintage kinds of things.
Um,
it's,
it's still running,
um,
as an emulated environment.
Uh,
on some Intel box somewhere,
there is a website you can all go to cyber one.org.
That's CYB are then the number one.
Dot.
Orgi um,
and,
uh,
a bunch of a former Plato engineers have kept all the software around.
Um,
they got permission from the University of Illinois to take the entire catalog
of many thousands of hours of educational lessons and stuff and the games and
all the,
all the famous games,
um,
which we probably audit to spend a moment about because,
uh,
the,
the games themselves are remarkable.
They're so many of them are the precursors to things that would come later that
would be hugely famous.
And you name it,
the type of game,
the certain design aspects of games,
you know,
uh,
the,
the first graphical d and d games.
We're clearly on Plato.
There was a game called d and d that was out in like 75.
Moria came out and around 75,
76,
which I played all the time.
It's,
it's still an incredible game.
It's on cyber.
One avatar came out and I have a whole chapter about all the dungeon games
called into the dungeon.
Um,
which is avatar was remarkable because,
um,
it was incredibly sophisticated.
And what you started seeing,
and this is also kind of interesting,
you know,
in the startup world today or the APP culture as it were,
everybody has an idea.
You go quickly develop an APP for a smartphone and you maybe get some VC money
and you know,
have your role at the dice.
Maybe you'll get lucky and get rich or whatever.
Um,
so many apps today are built as reactions to,
I would argue,
similar apps that have that predated and that you,
you have an idea for smarter,
faster,
better,
whatever your thing is.
That's,
you know,
er,
um,
that's going to improve upon what was built before.
And I would argue Google is a reaction to infoseek lycos and all the inadequate
search engines of the 90s.
Right.
Um,
page rank was the big breakthrough and Facebook is clearly reaction to my space,
which was a reaction to Friendster.
And you just keep going back to like a six degrees.com or something if anybody
was remit remembers that thing.
But,
um,
uh,
so you know,
that that's often the way it was.
And the same thing was happening.
That pattern was happening on Plato.
You know,
some kid would develop a game the next weekend,
some other kid would have said,
oh,
I have a better idea.
We'll change this and that,
and they'd come out with a game.
And so it was kind of like the
billboard top 40 of hit apps as it were,
you know,
um,
uh,
every week or even every day there'd be something new that was building upon and
improving upon some previous game or whatever.
And by the mid to late seventies,
um,
some of these high school kids were spending four years coding the game before
they were release it.
Avatar didn't release until about [inaudible] 79 they started working on it and
like 75,
76 when they were 13 years old and they wrote this entire operating system.
In fact,
they literally had operators who were to manage the data and all kinds of things
that were going on behind the scenes to manage the game cause it was so
complicated.
And um,
you know,
that had been built upon all the designs and thinkings of all the games that
came before it.
And,
um,
it was just remarkable.
And,
and then it would be years later,
we would start seeing the same pattern emerge with the web and with mobile apps
today until I think actually we're going to open it up for questions from the
audience too.
I,
if anybody has a question,
please go over to the mic and ask away.
Otherwise I have similar so that,
yeah,
please.
Thank you so much for
the talk and thank you so much for your time.
Um,
my question is,
so if you,
so what you're suggesting is things like,
let's say AOL instant messenger,
rhetorics,
maintenance messaging,
a ubiquitous was basically available 30 years for that,
right?
That to me suggests like a conspiracy somewhere that basically suppressed the
ideas that came out of Plato.
So then start recognize today as mainstream ideas.
So is that true or is it,
well,
a couple of comments.
One,
um,
uh,
if you've ever heard of the phrase patent troll,
um,
what's interesting about Plato is that it is the motherload of prior art.
So,
um,
in fact,
I've,
I've a couple of times been retained by attorneys for gigantic companies,
including Google that were sued by trolls.
I just realized,
yeah,
Google was one of the defendants in this giant,
ridiculous case of some crazy patent that no one had ever built the thing.
And they'd been selling it,
selling it,
and then somebody owned it and they tried to troll all the big companies.
Um,
and oftentimes the attorneys would go like,
this is a job for Plato,
you know,
because they knew that like somebody did it back.
Some kid did this very thing,
you know,
in like 1973 and sure enough,
um,
in that one case,
I remember I was involved in,
we were literally two days away.
We are making all the arrangements to truck a vintage,
uh,
terminal.
Probably one of the ones that the living computer museum here in town,
uh,
down to East Marshall,
Texas or wherever,
that infamous courthouses that does all the patent troll cases,
the United States.
Um,
Hi Marshall.
but,
uh,
apparently,
when they heard that,
you know,
I was going to give testimony and a demo of Plato and that I had been this
author of this book that was coming out and,
you know,
um,
that cost a settlement,
like,
like that,
you know,
so,
um,
it was unfortunate because that was really looking forward to demoing Plato to a
jury in Texas.
It would have been cool.
But,
um,
yeah,
so that,
that happened a lot.
So there's a lot of cases where,
um,
uh,
there's,
there are,
you know,
predecessors on Plato for things that would become commercial later.
Um,
and there are many cases that,
one of the things,
uh,
it's important understand that when Plato was,
the community was doing all this stuff in the early,
mid,
late seventies,
that was a time before there were software patents.
There was no method patent or,
or anything like that for software.
You could patent hardware and physical things,
but they hadn't yet.
I not,
I can't remember what year the software patents kicked in,
but,
um,
so that mindset didn't really exist.
And there was also,
since this was all on a university campus,
um,
it was all an educational and not for profit kind of thing.
So the motivation for all these kids that developed all these cool things was,
you know,
fame and glory online.
I mean,
that was what they lived for and they got it in droves.
You know,
they,
some of these people were like literally net dot celebrities before that term
existed,
you know.
Um,
and,
and just to give you a sense of how strange it was that,
you know,
Plato in a way I,
I sometimes liken it to the Galapagos.
It was a protected ecosystem that developed on its own.
Much of the rest of the world completely paid at zero tension and yet,
and so it didn't have any predators as it were.
And it was also a,
uh,
I guess you'd say from a network perspective,
homogenous network.
Um,
they were just Plato terminals connected over the network so they didn't have to
worry about interoperability.
Um,
one quick anecdote that,
that again,
will shed light on how obscure Plato became.
Um,
for years I was poking around looking through the RFC documents,
if you're familiar with them,
the request for comments,
there's thousands of them that formed the basis for all the specking that was
done to build the Internet.
And RFC 600 was always missing from every single repository.
And literally as of the early two thousands,
there were probably 50 RFC repositories on the line by then.
And every single one was missing number 600.
By then there were several thousand RFCs and I could never find RFC 600.
And the reason I was looking for it cause it had to do with Plato.
And so someone finally said,
Oh,
you need to talk to this guy who wrote it.
He's at,
he's in Santa Barbara somewhere.
He's probably retired.
So I tracked him down and he had a nice big long chuckle and he told me,
yeah,
the RFC 600,
uh,
was a proposal to connect what they called an Illinois plasma terminal to the
Arpanet.
And so I asked the guy,
why would you want to do that?
And he said to play the Games,
which I just thought that was a perfect response.
You know,
it was like,
you know,
they were bored doing this stuff on the arpanet that they could get access to
and they were probably tell netting and do long all the rest.
But they heard word that all the cool stuff was on Plato.
And,
uh,
unfortunately,
you know,
the packet network architecture of,
of,
of Arpanet and internet later was anathema to Plato's,
uh,
communications protocol,
which was designed again,
every bit as sacred.
The notion of a packet would be so wasteful.
All that overhead,
all those bits that,
or it could be used for data and they're just used for a dressing.
It's like,
are you nuts?
You know?
So again,
it's,
you know,
um,
everything was designed for speed on Plato 1200 bit per second serial or modem
connections and uh,
you know,
so it was a very different thing.
So,
you know,
I think they,
they,
they got it somewhat working,
but with packets and everything,
it would be like one character,
next character,
next character plotting of text.
It was,
it was unusable.
So do you have any theories on why some forward thinking things like potato
never had much of an effect on an industry while others like as you mentioned,
zero park had a lot of influence?
Um,
well that's an interesting question because I'm,
in fact a lot of the thinking on Plato did influence the industry and is still
influencing an industry.
There are,
there are Plato folks,
uh,
that worked at the,
at University of Illinois as student programmers and stuff that are,
that are still working at Google.
Um,
I know one guys is one of the,
I don't know if he's a director level or high level manager,
uh,
working on the data centers and stuff like that and the build out of all that.
Um,
so they're out there.
I mean,
uh,
I just saw a guy yesterday down in Silicon Valley,
um,
who worked at apple for like 20 years and you know,
uh,
a whole bunch of people came out from Illinois and went to apple and the,
you know,
first they did a tare,
then,
then they moved to apple and they did their 20 years at apple,
which when you think about it,
you know,
it must've been remarkable.
Um,
you know,
Steve Then,
no,
Steve,
then Steve Back,
you know,
that kind of history.
Right.
Um,
and uh,
but yeah,
there,
there are,
there probably the most famous case of a technology that inspired something that
became a multibillion dollar hit in the PC and internet world is lotus notes.
Lotus notes is named after Plato notes.
Plato nodes was written by a 17 year old kid named Dave wooly in 1973.
Um,
he was literally one of those kids at wandered in from across the street from
his local high school.
And,
um,
you know,
they wouldn't go away.
They,
they wouldn't be turned away.
and he just was so curious about the system.
He learned how to program.
And they said,
well,
we really need some kind of conferencing or message board system.
You know,
everything people need to be communicating 24,
seven asynchronously.
Like I don't know how to solve this problem.
So,
and it's,
it's two in the morning right now.
Maybe someone can answer this tomorrow,
let me post a note somewhere.
And so he went off and wrote Plato notes and uh,
shipped in it in August of two,
the of 1973 and a completely transformed everything on Plato.
It started the whole era of collaboration online with teams and everything.
And then of course,
they realize,
well,
we don't have to just talk about work subjects.
We could also talk about sports and music and movies and politics and all the
rest.
So sure enough,
all that stuff started to,
and uh,
you know,
all hell broke loose when that all started.
And,
um,
years later,
well actually in the 80s,
a when a couple of friends who had worked all as student programmers at the uni,
uh,
they went off to,
various companies and they decided to form a startup company in 1984 called iris
associates.
And that's,
that was where Lotus notes came from.
That's Ray Ozzie,
uh,
Tim Halverson and lend k.
Well,
Lynn Lynn lives right here in town somewhere.
Um,
he has a little startup,
I think right in Kirkland actually,
but,
um,
so they went off and did that and they,
they had funding and support from Lotus,
which was famous for one,
two,
three.
Um,
but not forever because Microsoft came out with excel.
Lotus needed something new.
They went with notes.
They shipped it as a $64,000 products.
Um,
and I think it was 1988 or 89.
It was a massive hit.
And enterprises,
um,
it wound up having about 110 million users.
It was sold.
Uh,
uh,
basically what's the last big product that load had?
And Lotus was sold to IBM for about three and a half billion dollars in about
95,
96 because of Lotus notes.
And if you look at the feature set of Lotus notes,
you know,
a lot of people would cringe day because we have open web and stuff,
Google docs and stuff like that.
But they didn't have that back then.
This was a stepping stone once again,
a reaction to what had gone before.
You know,
they,
they saw this great collaboration capability on Plato,
but now that could we bring all that to a local area network environment in an
enterprise.
And that's exactly what Lotus notes was.
It had very many of the same features as had been on Plato that had been written
by the kids back.
So a lot of technology made its way out.
A lot of games did too.
Um,
you know,
there were a bunch of Plato game authors that made the leap to apple to an IBM
PC.
Um,
and uh,
some of them became multimillionaires.
And in fact,
I have a whole chapter on one guy with an incredible life story.
Um,
I urge you to read it.
Uh,
this guy,
uh,
wrote,
one of the,
probably the most beautiful game on Plato called Mahjong,
and it was the tile,
the Chinese tile game,
a gorgeous graphics.
And I interviewed him in 1997 and I had seen him online in the 80s when I was on
Plato.
And I remembered he was very active in everything.
And halfway during the interview,
um,
I asked him a question or whatever,
and he mentioned,
oh,
by the way,
I'm in a wheelchair and I'm a quadriplegic.
And I programmed Mahjong with a mouth stick.
That's literally the only input he had.
And he had designed,
I have a full of really probably the best photo color photo in the book is the
screenshot of Mahjong.
It is staggering that he did that with a mouth stick.
He wrote all the code.
Then he bought a Macintosh in 1985 and he poured it all of the game to a,
I guess see language environment on the Mac.
Uh,
all the graphics and everything.
Again,
just using,
you know,
uh,
input devices for disabled people and an absolute miracle.
Um,
uh,
Activision licensed it,
published it,
and they sold 10 million copies and he now lives in Hawaii.
And I went out and visited him a couple of years ago and it was just absolutely
remarkable.
He's doing great.
Um,
you know,
and,
uh,
he's had it,
he's made a whole life or for himself.
Um,
and he tells me it was all because of Plato.
Plato saved his life.
He had,
he had a wrestling,
uh,
sorry,
gymnastics at accident at Stanford when he was an Undergrad.
He was on the Varsity gym team and he was in the gymnastics,
a gymnasium and was in the middle of doing a flip or something in practice one
day and landed in what was called the crash pit,
which is foam stuff.
There just wasn't enough foam and he broke his neck and he should have died
right on the spot.
And there was a whole cascade of coincidences and miracles that happened,
um,
that day and in subsequent days.
And I'll urge you to read the chapter to find out more.
So how's that for a teaser?
Thank you again for being here today.
Uh,
the topics of particular interest to me because I started college a year after
you did and the second programming job I ever had was writing courseware
unapplied us.
Cool.
I was wondering if anybody here,
you know,
uh,
had been been there and done that,
you know.
Yeah.
I didn't do it for a long time,
but um,
I was wondering,
um,
if you could elaborate a bit more as you,
somebody asked about,
you know,
what happened to it,
you talked about how it's still lose on like an emulator or annex CD six now,
but what from the,
like I was working on it like 81,
82,
something like that.
Um,
could you elaborate like what happened through the 80s and you just kind of die
a slow death or,
um,
it was,
uh,
kind of similar to what happened to digital equipment corporation.
Um,
if you remember,
you know,
they made faxes,
they were kind of important and a lot of people use them.
Now,
you know,
deck is this ancient history thing.
Um,
control data corporation was a major player in the computer industry and they
were based in Minneapolis,
Bloomington area.
And,
um,
uh,
you know,
their whole history was they sold mainframes,
they sold big iron,
and that was their whole mindset.
That was the whole salesforce was oriented to selling,
you know,
getting a customer to write a check for like five,
$10 million per box,
you know,
um,
they used to have a saying,
you know,
if you can plug it into the wall,
it's too small.
You know,
you needed a dedicated channel from the electric company to power one of their
things.
And,
um,
so,
you know,
Plato,
uh,
for a while fit in that model.
They could sell big mainframe systems with gazillions of terminals to go with
it.
So universities,
and they did that all over the world.
Um,
there,
there were,
played out a system set up,
you know,
University of Alberta,
University of Quebec,
probably,
you know,
maybe a dozen or more in the United States at various universities like
Delaware,
um,
uh,
all over the place.
And,
um,
so they really tried really hard to commercialize it,
but their timing,
once again,
you know,
timing is either good or bad and you know,
in the era where the microcomputer is just raging and it's like a free,
it's not only a freight train,
it's a freight train carrying freight trains of the future at you.
Right.
Um,
that was what was,
they were faced every single day.
So,
you know,
they might try to sell to university or to a gigantic school district and they'd
say like,
you know,
why should we spend $10 million on this system and then another maybe $10
million on telecommunication costs thanks to mob bell at the time.
Um,
you know,
uh,
people didn't realize that the phone lines often we're more expensive than the
hardware.
And I've already described how crazy expensive the hardware was.
Phone lines were even worse than that,
thousands per month and that kind of thing.
Um,
why should we buy all that stuff when there's like this apple to that Apple's
practically giving away.
We could buy a whole room full of them and still afford chalk,
you know,
for the classroom or whatever.
So it became a real problem.
And,
and uh,
uh,
so the company control data really struggled.
Um,
meanwhile the University of Illinois there,
you know,
that was the home of Plato.
That's where the lab was.
They were entrepreneurial too.
And they decided,
you know,
we're going to have to part ways with CDC and we're going to try to
commercialize it ourselves.
We tried with CDC,
it doesn't look like it's going to go and we still think we could do this.
And um,
so,
uh,
Don Bitzer,
who was the founder and the leader of the Plato Project,
had a vision still,
you know,
in the early eighties that he could get hundreds of thousands,
maybe millions of terminals connected all over the world on a network,
uh,
of servers essentially.
I mean,
what he was kind of envisioning was very similar to,
you know,
what Google has or any major net company now with data centers all over the
place,
you know,
fail safe,
redundant hardware.
Any server goes down,
you know,
the user never even notices,
it just flips to another server world.
That data is still there and it's all instantaneous and everybody's happy.
Um,
so they were thinking about those kinds of things even in the 80s.
And,
uh,
so Illinois,
spun off another project called Nova Net,
which was a commercial venture to commercialize Plato.
And that actually did well.
That actually did commercially well.
And it survived until just a couple of years ago.
In fact,
the epilogue of the book is the final night when,
when no vanette shuts down.
And,
and uh,
I reluctantly stayed up late that night waiting for this thing to shut down.
And of course,
you know,
the,
whoever was supposed to shut it down at like two in the morning was the late.
So there were like 22 people.
These die hard Plato folks,
um,
hanging around,
chatting in the notes files and in turn talking stuff for a couple of hours.
Watch waiting just for the thing to shut down an issue.
The,
you know,
Nova Net will be shutting down in 60 seconds.
Dot Dot.
Dot.
Nova Nova.
We'll be shutting down in 30 seconds.
Dot.
Dot,
dot.
You know,
10 seconds then,
you know,
Nova is gone.
And that was it.
It's,
it's,
it,
they've by,
uh,
the early two thousands,
I believe it was,
um,
Nova that had been acquired by a whole chain of companies,
like one fish eating another fish,
bigger fish,
ate that fish.
And it was now owned by Pearson,
the gigantic global conglomerate that ironically had gobbled up a bunch of
plaintiffs competitors from the,
from the eighties and nineties as well.
And,
um,
but they had decided it was time to go web and use different technology and
different product lines.
So Nova net was finally,
you know,
quietly shut down.
But what's important to get back to your question is that,
um,
you know,
uh,
no vanette found on a market and,
and it wasn't one that was sexy or you know,
cool and wasn't going to be written about and wired.
Um,
it was basically,
um,
remedial education and,
you know,
uh,
the,
the last chance for high school kids for example,
who are struggling and we're going to be kicked out of school permanently
because they just didn't have the learning skills or they had learning
difficulties.
Um,
one thing that was discovered early on Plato's that,
um,
students who have those kinds of difficulties do really well interacting with
the computer because none of the social peer pressures of performing well in
front of all these other kids in their class.
Um,
none of that existed.
You could have a one on one interaction with the computer teacher and,
um,
if you made a mistake and the screen said no try again,
you wouldn't get laughed at in the classroom.
And they also discovered that Plato at a gigantic market in prison education.
So in,
uh,
prisons all over the United States in the seventies and eighties,
Plato was used to,
uh,
provide GED training and things like that job training so that,
you know,
some inmate could get out and get a job and have skills and even get a degree.
And it turned out to be incredibly successful.
And,
and that was one of the,
the markets that really worked,
which was,
you know,
who knew,
you know.
All right.
So we're close to the end of the hour.
A couple of things there.
I think only two of us in the room,
and I'm not one of them who have actually seen a news to Plato system,
but that can be different Saturday,
uh,
because,
at one o'clock at the living computer museum,
uh,
Brian is going to go and he's going to give a talk about his book,
and then they're going to have a two hour session after they're actually two
running systems there.
So I encourage anybody who's interested to go and take a look.
Uh,
and that's this Saturday.
And,
uh,
also we have a few more books for sale with the Google subsidy.
There are half price,
so they're only $20 a and yeah,
Brian will stick around,
I think,
to sign him afterwards.
And,
uh,
other than that list,
thank Brian for coming.
Thank you.
[inaudible].